[Music]
the humble butterfly is a fun and
beautiful move and it can really look
like a butterfly flapping its wings if
the planes are really close together but
you've probably noticed that when you're
learning it they will sometimes crash to
some degree that's inevitable it's part
of the learning process but there's a
couple of hints that will make that
learning process go quicker and I've
seen this work hundreds of times you
have to actually do it
take your poi or if you're showing play
to somebody get them to wrap the poi
around their hands and hold just the
ends of the play then to do a butterfly
with their arms and you'll notice you
might have a preference either the right
arm on top or the left arm on top so
let's for now talk about the right arm
on top and you can do all of this with
the left arm on top
in the beginning ultimately you want
both ways so what I want you to notice
is this if your right arm passes closer
to your body at the top it has to be
outside at the bottom further from your
body and I've never seen anybody not be
able to do this yet so if it's closer at
the top and further at the bottom it's
on an angle like this it's tilted
towards you
the other play my left arm is further at
the top and closer at the bottom so it's
plane is tilted away from me so my right
arm is tilted towards me and my left arm
is tilted away and that's why they don't
hit you can test if your right hand your
right poi passes closer at the top and
tries to also plot pass closer at the
bottom that's when they crash if you're
right poised on top what needs to happen
is the bottom of that circle needs to
fire away from your feet it's as simple
as that
if it does this same like the left poi
they will crash if you can keep that top
boy firing away from your feet tilted
towards your face just a little bit they
won't crash so as you're doing the
butterfly you need to get a top boy to
go
fire fire fire and you're pushing the
bottom of the circle away it's subtle
but this is what will make them not
crash to be able to do that you have to
use one play at a time this is another
thing when people do it it works but
often they won't do it and just for some
minutes but practice tilting it like
this back to straight tilting it like
that
until you get a sense of what you need
to do to make the angle of the poi tilt
like this when you go back to two POI
try to do that a little bit so that top
poi does a bit of that angle you will
soon find they're crashing less they
look crash this will take a little
practice as it begins to work what is
really helpful is to exaggerate those
angles then slowly and straighten onto a
wall plane more and more and more and
more until the poi finally start to hit
and then angle more and then let me get
straighter and straighter and straighter
until they hit if you keep doing that
that's where you're taking the steps
towards a real mastery about how this
move works because ultimately you want
them passing really close because it's
when they pass close that you get that
effect of a butterfly flapping its wings
a space butterfly a space organism with
circular boy like wings and that's it
when people do those practices from what
I've seen it really helps you gotta do
it doesn't take too long and I wish you
lots of luck and success
with your bird flies
[Music]